said yesterday if the prime minister
attended this gathering party event in
downing street on the 20th of may then
he could not continue as prime minister
so regretfully i have to say that his
position is no longer terrible you think
the boris johnson should resign as prime
minister
i made that clear and there was one
simple question to answer yesterday
indeed since monday night when we saw
this invitation which was to more than
100 people asking them to join others in
the down street garden and bring their
own booze if the prime minister was
there and he accepted today that he was
then i felt he could not continue what
we also heard from the prime minister
today was an apology and he said with
hindsight he would have done things
differently which for me is uh an
acceptance from the prime minister that
it was wrong and therefore
i don't want to be in this position but
i am in the position now where i don't
think he can continue as leader of the
conservatives have you told boris
johnson that i spoke to the prime
minister this afternoon and i set out my
reasons and i explained to him
my position how did he respond uh i
think discussions between myself and the
prime minister understandably remain
between us he believes that he didn't do
anything wrong and he has put up a
defense for his position but i also have
to to look at the information i've got
in front of me
and to stick with the position that i
made quite clear yesterday that if he
did attend that party he couldn't
continue his prime minister it's quite a
brave quite bold thing to do to be the
first out of the traps to call for the
prime minister's resignation
do you feel a bit concerned about that
i've got a position to take as an
individual mp and as leader of the
scottish conservatives to respond to
understandable questions from the media
and others and i've taken a position
whether i'm the first or the last to me
doesn't make much of a difference i've
got to look at what i've said in the
past what others were asked to do at
that time and what the prime minister
himself has accepted he did and for
which he has apologized for
how much support do you think there is
within the scottish conservatives for
your position on this well again this is
a position that i've taken as as an
individual mp and msp
i know speaking to colleagues here in
the scottish parliament and
in the uk parliament there is
significant
um
unrest and
concern about the actions that took
place in downing street on the 20th of
july 20th may 2020. do you think that
boris johnson will try and tough this
out i i think so you know we saw it
prime minister's questions today he put
up a defense to the leader of the
opposition and other mps who are asking
these questions
but i'm in a position where i've got to
look at what i've said in the past what
the prime minister has accepted he did
himself in his response in the house of
commons today and that's why i'm
regretfully in this position that i'm
calling for him to go to and everyone
else can see that he's broken the rules
so you just think his position is
completely untenable now yes because the
evidence is clear people were invited to
bring their own booze to enjoy the
garden at downing street that is by any
definition a party a gathering that that
wasn't allowed and therefore the prime
minister to break his own rules how
quickly should he go
that's a decision for the prime minister
i can only give my view and i'm trying
to be upfront and honest with people
i don't enjoy this i get no enjoyment
out of calling for this but i just feel
i've got a duty as an individual
to explain my position and the reason
i've come to this conclusion today
you're also an mp if he doesn't go
should the mps decide to hold a motion
of no confidence and a vote of no
confidence in him well that's up to
individual mps at what they do but i
think we have seen across the house some
pretty
um
really
quite galling stories about how people
were affected either themselves or by
their constituents and i think there is
a strength appealing across the
political spectrum that this is a most
serious issue but if he doesn't resign
do you think the party should get rid of
him well that's my view as an individual
that i don't think his position as
leader of the conservatives and prime
minister is tenable in the future do you
regret backing him in 2019 for the
leadership well no i don't because in
2019 he promised a vision for the united
kingdom he delivered a record result for
the conservatives certainly in recent
years i was proud and privileged to
serve under him as a minister i've
worked closely with him this is a prime
minister who
quite often is
in the news for what people think he's
done wrong but let's remember the
vaccine rollout that he spearheaded his
government leg has saved so many lives
the self-employed income support scheme
the job retention scheme these are
things brought in by boris johnson and
his government that he is right to be
proud of and the way we have fought this
pandemic and many other things and
that's why this is a difficult decision
for me this is why it's it's something i
don't do lightly but i also can't ignore
the facts that we have in front of us
which was he did attend a party that he
shouldn't have so what does this leave
your relationship with the wider
conservative party across the uk well
that's something we'll see in the coming
days weeks and months but i think people
knew when i put myself forward as leader
of the scottish conservatives that you
know i take strong
opinions and views and i stick with them
and some people will agree with my
decision some people will disagree and
that is the nature of politics but in my
role in my position i've got to come to
conclusion and that's what i've done
today and as a result of him attending
this party you don't think he's fit to
be prime minister i don't think he can
continue as leader of the conservative
party and prime minister asking people
to follow the rules and guidance of his
government but i don't believe he did